if you're wired the way i'm wired and
you're very mechanical and pragmatic it
does
make
no sense to you know
you
you turn on the tv in the
los angeles um commissioner's board or
the la council committee or whatever
is
seven insane women in their mid-sixties
wearing masks on zoom calls
talking about you know re-masking the
kids before we open the schools and
comparing wearing a mask to wearing
shoes you don't think wearing shoes is
restrictive it's more restrictive than
wearing a mask like
just insane middle-aged cows
setting policy so yes it is it is a i
for a guy like me i would i would like
somebody with some experience in the
private sector
making normal decisions for the citizens
i'm dave rubin and as you guys know i am
off the grid for august in an
undisclosed location but we went ahead
and pre-taped some incredible fabulous
wonderful groundbreaking interviews for
you in july and joining me today is the
host of the adam corolla show and the
author of many books i believe this is
his sixth but his newest book right here
in my hand everything reminds me of
something advice answers but no
apologies adam carolla welcome back to
the reuben report always good to see you
dave corolla uh i have to have a little
maya culpa up top here i'm off the grid
right now and as i'm interviewing you
just a few days before the end of july i
have not read the book yet because i'm
going to read it in august but is it
fair to say this is your best work ever
no
but
it's up there
and you know you have to understand my
best work ever is pretty damn funny
this is pretty damn funny too i it's
it's really hard to kind of rank them
people like in 50 years will all be
chicks you know and they like not taco
bell material but
you know i it's hard for me to do it but
if you go on uh amazon it had a 4.8 it
toggles between like a 4.7 star and a
4.8 star my other books are
four five four six you know so it's uh
yeah it arguably is ranked a little a
little higher review-wise
but uh it's it's up there everything's
above a 4.5
i think what you're really trying to say
is that your best work does involve a
trampoline is that what you're really
saying that's there and it's all in the
rearview mirror
speaking of the rear view mirror uh i
don't see you in person anymore because
i left california in the rear view
mirror you're still there you're on the
short list of sane people how's it going
over there you all right do you need any
money or help what can i do for you
it's uh not good you know um i know
people always kind of talk about the
grid and wildfires and you know
homelessness and
and uh
drug trafficking and uh crime street
crime and everything but i i will sort
of paint you a a picture of how la and
california is doing
we tried to open a bridge in la like two
weeks ago and it had to be closed down
because too much
street racing too many
people climbing it and threatening to
jump off too much graffiti there we
literally attempted to open a bridge
in the middle of la
to the tune of 600 million dollars
and two weeks after it was opened it's
now closed
because
the people
could not
figure out a way to walk across it
without tagging it threatening to jump
off or or shivving somebody with a shank
that's so you're saying i made the right
decision is that what you're telling me
i i think so i mean you have bridges in
florida and they're mostly open seem
fine to me
from what i can talk you're gonna get a
gator under them every now and again but
they're functioning and uh you just go
to the other side
and it's humid they're talking okay
we're talking about putting speed bumps
in this bridge
and putting a medium in the middle of it
because people can't stop from doing
donuts in the middle of the bridge
i feel like the nonsense of la and
california must be particularly hard for
a guy like you because if when i think
of you first you're very functional you
like things that work you're a
contractor you like things that make
sense
and yet you live in a place where
nothing makes sense have you thought
about that spiritually
yeah if you're wired the way i'm wired
and you're very mechanical and pragmatic
it does
make
no sense to you know
you
you turn on the tv in the
los angeles um
commissioner's board or the la council
committee or whatever
is
seven insane women in their mid 60s
wearing masks on zoom calls
talking about you know re-masking the
kids before we open the schools and
comparing wearing a mask to wearing
shoes you don't think wearing shoes is
restrictive it's more restrictive than
wearing a mask like
just insane middle-aged cows setting
policy so yes it is it is a i for a guy
like me i would i would like somebody
with some experience in the private
sector
making normal decisions for the citizens
it's like it's like being in a city run
by the ladies of the view i really don't
know how you do it anymore yeah honestly
exactly that's exactly what it is this
is exactly what it is it's just an
insane
um
cadre
of yentas who have feelings about
wearing masks and have you know it's
like rachelle wilinski head of the cdc
when she was up there like i'm speaking
as a mother i have a bad feeling like no
one gives a [ __ ] about your feelings
witch just make some policy would you i
don't care that look out all right i'll
tell you what i'm a dad
and i got a bad feeling that the schools
are going to be closed and that my son's
going to have to wear a mask for no
reason so are we even now
in the feelings department
i feel like you just gave ben shapiro a
great idea for his next book no one
gives a [ __ ] about your feelings witch
that feels like you could co-write that
with him i think
i'd love it
so uh i believe because i do do my
research although i said i i'm going to
read this thing in august i believe in
chapter four you say you're going to
stay till your kids are out of high
school and then you're going to get the
hell out is that is that really the plan
oh yeah you have to you can't
run a business or you know try to
function in la or california
any other way i mean i guess
you could work for the tsa
i imagine and stay in california but
you can't practically do it if you're
trying to
run a run a business so yes i would have
to leave
speaking of the craziness of the world
uh as we're recording this right now it
sounds like we're in a recession as of
this morning on july 28th we are in a
recession although uh they have thus
changed the definition of recession in
real time and edited on wikipedia um
things don't seem to be going very well
did they edit it on wikipedia there's
been 30 as of today there's been 37
edits on the official recession page on
wikipedia but you can see it all over on
cnn everybody's editing you know they're
just a recession isn't too
consecutive quarters of gdp going down
now it also there's other factors and
and the feelings thing and all that
yeah it's it's really interesting
i always think about kamala harris
talking to lester holt about the border
and he's like have you been to the
border and she's like oh uh well
yeah we've been to the border
you've been to the border we have and
then he goes
but have you been to the border and
she's like
i haven't been to europe what are we
talking about
the most interesting thing about that
exchange is not her sort of lying
it's her at the end she goes
i i don't know what you're asking like
you don't know what i'm asking you
you're the borders are
let's just say you're the queen of the
mardi gras parade
and i said have you been to mardi gras
would you be confused and go i don't
know what you i don't know what you're
asking or
that's the craziest part about
this sort of new world order which is
like this weird semantic overload thing
where we just get bogged down and what
what is a recession what's a border i
don't know it's it's all invisible we
can't define what's a woman i i can't
exactly so it's not definable so how are
we gonna i mean it's like it's like you
go in like when you're in the sixth
grade and you're like you you go in and
teachers like did you bring your
homework and you went
what's homework
uh it's the assignment that was assigned
to you when you left on friday i don't
know what that yes there i have seen
homework if that's what you're asking
like it's just weird circle talk
and it's by the way
uh you dodged a bullet because you're
gay but uh when you argue with women
that's how you argue you start to talk
about things
you don't even know what you're talking
about anymore
and and that's kind of the new world
order what what is a recession i don't
know here's how i define it if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the non-stop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell